- This is my first time on television.
- Oh, you mean not doing a Zoom?
- Yeah.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah, this is my first in
studio, it's very exciting.
Hi everybody!
- You look so beautiful!
- Thanks!
- I mean, I need people to know
that even when you're at her house
and you're having dinner,
even in her simple clothes,
you feel less than.
(audience laughter)
- You're crazy!
- You're like, "Is that
what God intended?"
- No, oh my goodness.
Just sitting down, I've been
doing this crazy EMS workout,
electro muscle stimulation,
and my whole butt hurts
so just sitting down.
- Wait, does that mean
it works out for you?
- It's 20 minutes but it's like
working out for four hours.
and you're hooked up to this moist wetsuit
with electronic stuff
stuck to your muscles,
and then you do little
movements through it,
and then we're all just dying.
All my hair and makeup people, everybody.
We're all dead.
- Everybody sees your body and right now,
(Chrissy laughs)
I think the internet is gonna crash
because everyone is racing to get this.
- No, no.
I'm actually gaining weight through out
and I'm like, "Oh,
that's just muscle right?
Yeah, it's for sure muscle.
(Kelly laughs)
- That's what my friend
said, she was like,
"How am I working out and getting fatter?"
- I think you get cocky
with food, that's why.
- Ah, I just do that in general.
(Chrissy laughs)
So you and John spent the
Grammy nights dressed like this
which, this is amazing!
Look at you!
- [Chrissy] We got bored.
- [Kelly] Was that just in your closet?
- We were so bored, I texted
one of my stylists, Monica
and I was like, "I feel so bad."
Because she had been asking
me for months if we were going
and then, I was under the
impression there was no Grammy's
and then you know what it's like
when your award isn't televised
and then you're like, "Oh
I probably didn't win,"
or whatever.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then they're like, "John
your award is televised!"
And I was like, "You won!"
- Oh! (Kelly laughs)
He did win!
- He won the un-televised one, yeah.
(audience claps)
- Yeah but whatever, it's
best R&B album right?
- [Chrissy] I know!
- Yeah!
- [Kelly] I have another photo though,
so I wanna ask you about what's happening-
- [Chrissy] Oh God! (laughs)
This went over well.
- [Kelly] Did it not?
(Chrissy laughs)
- I was backstage in your
beautiful dressing room,
you have hands-down the best dressing room
of any talk show out there, always.
- (gasps) Thank you! Thanks!
- This is even better, somehow.
Okay so anyway, I've been
backstage just on my Twitter like
as my daily thing is threatening to quit
or threatening to deactivate,
and then this one I was like,
"Oh Instagram's nice though!"
And then nope, they showed
me that they were upset.
- What happened? What do you mean?
- We were trying to
take beauty glam photos
and he was just in the middle of it
but yeah people were really
bothered by it, I don't know.
- My son's hilarious anytime
he walks in my bathroom
and I happen to be naked or something
and he's always like, "Naked baby!"
(Chrissy laughs)
- Naked baby!
- And I'm like, now I feel dirty about it.
- My daughter, Luna's
always like, "Naked baby!"
- [Kelly] That's what my kids do!
- And I mean, we take baths
together, I don't see the issue.
- I think everybody's
comfort level is different
but here's my favorite part about any
of this social media stuff.
I love that you clap back, and I love that
the most interesting concept to me is,
why do people -
- follow you?
- I know.
- Follow you, If they don't like you
or if they have a problem
with what you're doing?
- [Chrissy] I know.
- It is the most interesting thing to me,
cause I don't have time!
- Cause I have the time, I
do, and I'll go to their page,
and it's always they follow
me and their page is private,
without hesitation, every
time it's like that.
- Wow!
- But yeah, you cause you
think they'd know by now,
I haven't changed through all these years.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- It's just yeah I think people -
- And your social media
account is supposed to be
a representation of who you
are, like this is who you are,
so like OK cool you don't like it?
Bye!
- And what's really weird
is the psychology of it
like really learning about people
because obviously we had a
really weird, rough year,
and then when people decide
that their pity for you is over,
and "Oh, it's noon and it's
time to be mean again,"
like, now it feels appropriate?
- Yeah.
- It's such an odd, icky
thing to look at people doing
like it just felt like
honestly one weekend,
everyone was like, "Oh we don't
feel bad for them anymore,
and we're gonna do this."
- Wow.
- I remember going through all of that,
going through all the
emotion after a miscarriage,
or a stillborn, and
telling John that like,
"Wow, the amount of love
we're getting both in person
and online is like, unheard of for me,
I'm not used to this!"
And then just one day, it was over.
- Now that's just a sad statement!
- Yeah.
- My big thing now is I just want to
follow all the same people I
follow, maybe work with Twitter
but not allow anyone to follow me.
- Oh.
- And I don't want to ever
speak, but I want my same list-
- Yeah.
- of people that I follow
because I genuinely,
it's been 11, 12 years on Twitter now
so those are my buddies!
- Wow!
That's a long time, I forgot.
- Yeah, it's a long time
to take a constant beating.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But you, (groans)
You would think it would
make you stronger, no!
I think weakened me.
- Do you go and I go
emotionally, like being
in the limelight in general,
I go like a roller coaster.
- [Chrissy] Yeah.
- Like not a severe one,
but kinda like a woo!
Cause some days I'm just
like, "I can handle anything!"
I'm like, whatever.
And other days I'm like, "Why?"
- Some days I'm like, "I
have a beautiful family,
a perfect husband, like I
really have an incredible life."
- Blessed.
- And some days I'm like,
"I don't know if I can do this anymore-
- Yeah.
- like this is overwhelming,
I don't know I can be on here
and interact with people
that want me to fail.
- But that's what I like about you,
you're not perfect online.
That's what I like, and even in person,
like even us at dinner,
like you're not perfect,
you're very normal and you're
very raw in the moment.
I think that is so freaking refreshing,
- Thank you.
- 'cause I don't think
most people are like that.
- It's hard to make mistakes
in front of everybody,
- Yeah.
- for that many years.
- But I love that you own it,
and you're like, "That's me!"
And then maybe you think it's a mistake,
like even if you do make
a mistake you apologize
but at the same time might
not be a mistake to you.
You might be like, "Well
that's just who I am
or how I am."
- Well tell that to my therapist
because they are just like
itching for me to talk to them.
- Well, why don't we trade?
You can talk to my therapist
and I'll talk to yours!
(Chrissy and Kelly laugh)
- We'll probably have the
same issues, we're so similar.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] I don't know I hope you don't.
(audience cheers)
- I wanna discuss a serious
topic with you as well,
so, we're seeing protests
against anti-Asian violence,
and I just wanna know your thoughts on it.
- It's actually what's been
happening has been incredible.
A lot of people have
been reaching out to me
and wondering how they
can help, what they can do
and I love to post tangible
things that people can do
because there's all sorts
of performative activism.
- Mm-hmm.
- I think we just came out
of a long line of politicians
that put a target on Asian people's backs
by calling it "the China virus,"
and so people are seeing Asian
people out on the street,
I automatically think of like
when my mom's without me,
how do people look at her?
How do people treat her?
A lot of mothers and
fathers are being targeted
around the country and
it is so obvious to me
what the motive is, it
doesn't seem to be obvious
to the politicians out there
that are saying like, "We're
not quite sure of the motive."
But I think we know what it
is and if people can just
reach out in any way to support the
Asian-American community, AAPI in general,
there's Stop AAPI Hate, which
is a wonderful organization
to donate to, and an organization
called 18 Million Rising
is really incredible, but
also it's little things
like supporting Asian-owned
businesses around you,
supporting your local Chinatown,
I mean these things are
disappearing quicker
than we know it and soon
they're gonna be gone
and it's heartbreaking to me
so support any way you can.
Don't just be the person
that reaches out via text
and checking in on you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We all have to have
each others backs in this
because Asian Americans are Americans!
They came here for, my
mother came here for the
American dream, she
got to have a cookbook!
- My great grandfather did the same thing!
- Yeah!
- We're all immigrants, we're
all from immigrants yeah.
- And it's nobody's birth
right here that they are
the only ones to enjoy
the fruits of America,
that's just not a fact.
There is plenty for everybody
and we should welcome anyone
who wants to come here
to make their dreams possible, that's it.
- Yeah, I think especially
having children it's so hard,
and your children!
- It's so odd because
they are so young still,
they're 2 and 4, Luna almost 3 and 5.
- They will start picking
up though, especially Luna.
- I know, and right now I
think what we talk about a lot
is representation,
representation in the media
and representation in Disney shows.
Rya The Last Dragon was
incredible for us to see-
- I love Raya!
- on television, Luna's
like, "Uncle has a Tuk Tuk"
and "Oh, we eat rice
porridge in the morning"
and "She has hair like me!"
And you know it's just,
You know first hand, I'm sure,
that kids notice things so early,
- Yeah.
- they notice how they're unique-
- Sponges!
- and they notice their
differences and yeah and at school
and they just happen to
be more vocal about it
so it's important to explain it to them
in the simplest of ways
that they're different
but they're beautiful, they're unique.
But yeah, it's so crazy
to me that Luna can look
at a princess and be like,
"Why don't I have blonde, straight hair?"
And I'm like, "It's different
but it's beautiful, don't worry!"
- Yeah, alright so wait I
need to talk about this,
just sitting here this is awesome.
We need to talk about your new
brand of cleaning products.
- Yes!
- The line is called Safely, my hope
'cause I don't know if
you're a mom like me,
I don't like anything
that might be damaging,
you know, for my kids.
- No, of course! Pets and
children, this is all safe.
It's made with aromatherapy oils-
- Whoa!
- so the smell that lingers is really nice
and really beautiful and
really clean smelling
and the best part for me is
that you can use it on
all different surfaces.
So we started out really
small with just a few items,
but the few crucial items that we need
because Kris and Emma are like
the most incredible
entrepreneurs out there,
everyone says like, "Oh girl boss!"
And I'm like, "No, no, no, bosses."
They're just bosses.
And so when they came
to me about this product
and wanting to shake up the
world of cleaning products,
I was really excited for it
because we are paying attention
to labels so much more
in this pandemic and
honestly everyone's like,
"Kris Jenner doesn't clean!"
And I'm like, "Are you kidding me,
she's the cleanest person I know!"
You'll be talking to her on a couch
and she'll be eyeballing
something in the corner
and then she'll just quickly
get up and go pick it up.
She notices if I have something on my shoe
when I come in her house,
like she's a nutcase about it
and she's crazy!
- Are you a neat freak?
- I'm like a-
- Your house was spotless!
- I know, I am a neat freak.
- When I came over for dinner.
- John is so different,
he's clean, but not neat.
So he looks like the invisible
man, like after he goes pee,
and then he takes his
clothes off, it'll be like,
shoes, and then like
the piping of the jeans
will still be in the shoes and I'm like,
"Are you a firefighter?"
Like are you setting this
up so you can get back
into it really quick again?
(Kelly laughs)
But yeah, he's clean not neat.
But I come from the
blogging world of like,
constantly filming yourself cooking
and so my recipes take so much longer
because I clean in between
absolutely everything.
I do every dish, I clean
all the countertops
because I need it to
look pretty at all times
so I've always been a nut about it.
- I love cleaning, I find it therapeutic.
- Me too!
- Yeah, well good news for everyone
in our house seats y'all, you
are all getting the full line
of Safely Home Cleaning Products!
- [Chrissy] Enjoy it!
- [Kelly] I love you.